to do that i know you really want to go
and also um this is headset huh and also
that's the wrong answer
and also i want to say that um
i'm deep back into destiny he is and um
i'm in old old like old school
wait hold on because the new dlc for
fallout comes out when
now oh you're back to that bro no i'm
not i'm playing destiny right now yeah i
mean he's back on 12 hours a day i've
been reading the reviews
everyone's like it's the [ __ ] i don't
even play fallout i don't even play [ __ ]
i don't have that
find me uncharted 4 ps4
guild bits and um
[Music]
so that's that
thank you he's been very deep into it
guys it's back to the old screaming at 3
a.m your sister's a lot then well i
didn't wake up i didn't sleep until noon
he didn't sleep till noon
oh whoa babe if you're gonna be in this
room be on the mic
jesus christ
i didn't sleep till noon i woke up at
six mm-hmm
are you playing with steve and eric yeah
well eric's in spain
so me steve craig and um
frankie but um
[Music]
it's back back to the grinding of it so
you're not going to play fallout anymore
even if the dlc drops
well i mean the dlc is more things for
your house
like elevators
elevators weapon and weapon display
cases it's like okay
no one's gonna see this when you're
building this stuff you're like oh this
is cool
look at what i did with the
the land that they gave me so you're
[ __ ] on fallout now then no what i'm
saying is is that but when you're
building your 90th house you're going
wait a second
who gives a [ __ ] no one's seeing this no
one's seeing your kills on destiny
either yeah they do your friends see it
steve sees it yes they see it what's
your light level
you'll get there dude
and then you're like oh [ __ ]
yeah oh it's competition
that's what he desires tenacity
he he desires competition
so long you know what but that's fine
because i have destiny now again oh
how's that been awful
you like you were never going back to
fallout would you say that
well a new dlc came out last we're gonna
even to play it yet he hasn't he's full
on destiny i didn't even tempt you at
all you ever had like a few episodes ago
you said you were so done with destiny
it's such a far memory a distant memory
i'm going to tell you what happened you
two
okay
i really believe that i go i'm never
going to play the stupid game again it's
a point it's a waste it's pointless
so fallout came out finally i have a
game but
i'm building my 50th house
in fallout collecting
concrete and steel and
and i'm building the third floor of this
new house on this new land
and i'm going why the [ __ ] am i doing
this
no one's gonna see this
this is just for me
right
and secondly this is what happened
there's a mexican now
i'm sorry it came out wrong yeah mexican
person okay okay thank you for adding
person yeah yeah
i was going to say mexicana but i said
mexico
a mexicano yeah comedian named frank
you know he works at the comedy store
he's a doorman
him eric griffin and my brother you know
are playing
destiny this whole time
so not only do i get it from eric
griffin and steve every day going
come on dude it's different you gotta
join us
please we need your help
i have this little mexicano you know man
frank hey bro you got to play with it
every time i go to the conference every
night
it doesn't sound like that by the way
yeah yeah but i still do it i like it
but i want to do it hey bro
you gotta play with us bro
right
and um i just had enough
i'm like you know what i have nothing
i'm tired of fallout so you are tired of
fallout i'll try it again okay
but the the
slow graduation back into 100 destiny
has not been fun for me because the
first night
the first night was fairly quiet there
was no screaming there was no cursing
okay and now we're day nine and all you
hear in the middle of the night [ __ ] you
craig craig
you know what i call you craig dust
booth because you're a sinking submarine
just crazy [ __ ] like he'll tell his
brother like you know why you're not in
the military because
you'd be a a
a a sergeant like restocking toilet
paper and you'd still get killed by a
landmine wait this is your teammates
he tells them how much he sucks they
they all suck and he's like i'm not and
i can hear them steve's like bobby look
you're being a dick you're being a dick
bro don't say that no no no no no stop
babe
you're b you're awful no you're awful or
even saying that i'm awful all right
you're not seeing it in context
what happened i hear everything i know
you do but you're not watching and hit
these two fools
for the last five months while i was
playing fallout
they were playing destiny 24 7. so they
should be better than you and they
should be they should be the leader
they should be leading me and teaching
me but they're not they're running
around in circles
going we don't know where we're going on
right and i'm going
this is what you learned
in five [ __ ] months you [ __ ]
and so let me say something
when you and eric griffin is he good
no but eric griffin
does what i he's in spain yeah yeah to
see his mom
so no one's there to like lay down the
law
oh so when you talk to people that way
because i have the power seat yeah yeah
i'm older i'm kind of famous
look at me gross it's grown across
you know man nobody knows who they are
yeah yeah and i have a little fan base
yeah yeah
power right and so i can say things like
you [ __ ] losers
you know i mean like kill yourselves
mm-hmm you know what that when i talked
at that you know what happens what does
steve do we start winning
ah because they get angry interesting it
works every time it's like full metal
jacket it's a tactic that's what he does
every time and craig and steve are like
what's his name sergeant pyle like the
fat guy in full metal jacket and he's
just a guy screaming in his face you're
a boot camp sergeant yeah you are yeah
yeah
yeah right do it right yeah don't do it
at all
so we're doing this thing called um
trials of osiris
so you're a team of three guys and you
fight three other guys okay
and there's a little map just pvp yeah
okay three against three
i'm not exaggerating
we last night we probably did
46 matches between three random people
we won one
how did you even want to continue after
losing five in a row i'll tell you why
that's so because they give you these
bounties
and it says if you kill 50 people and
you you complete seven matches right
you you'll get a random gift a gold tier
gift you which is usually i got a really
sweet gun the other day right so that's
what it is
so you go you know what we just did 10
matches we didn't get a single kill but
we need to get 50 kills that's why we
have to do 46 [ __ ] matches
damn i'm just losing them i'm losing
yeah and so it gets to a point where
like
you know i mean like craig who's my
brother's
you know
neighbor
nice guy you know i mean a heavyset
white nerd sure nice guy right and he's
trying to go
bubba you go into this room no
because we did that last time and well
you died we all died
so my thing is
fend for yourselves
so you just go you just go i just leave
them and go fend for yourselves oh you
don't do any teamwork it's just like let
me get my kills you cannot tell retards
what to do in a team situation
you know i'm sorry but and i i i know
people that have kids that have
mental deficiencies i apologize
deficiencies
but god
if i'm in a real battle
deficiency if i'm really in a real
battle and my
platoon are a bunch of people that have
down syndrome or
you know what i mean stuff like that
right mental situations sure situation
is that better that's yeah right
i'm a sergeant i'm like hey toby
yeah we'll do that where where i go
yeah yeah that's good okay toby yeah go
to that foxhole all right hook up with
jim and flank us there's a bunny that
that's exactly what it is i see you're
frustrated you would be frustrated
that's exactly what i did yeah there's a
bunny and now toby's out you know me in
another field somewhere chasing a bunny
around yeah he gets shot and yeah and
we're all dead just don't say hi to me
jeez
okay
don't go anywhere near me
you hear that no am i why am i so angry
is it because of destiny i think it's
destiny man steroids you're not on
steroids no i don't do that anymore
i don't what i don't do destiny i mean
that's the one thing that i definitely
noticed about him when the difference
between when you playing destiny versus
um fallout you become a very very
confrontational person when you're on
desktop because competition with people
that's why i have to sit back and really
hold my tongue because he really likes
to go full charge into a fight how about
this why don't you get into gaming
um i like i do i like outside
no oh no that's not true i like i like
her and i play what game bejeweled blitz
oh i saw a snap i saw a snapchat
there's a snapchat well let me explain
what went down okay go ahead i actually
scored the highest score like ever ever
[ __ ] scored in bejeweled blitz in the
history of my facebook account or in his
facebook so you beat him what'd you get
three six but yeah it froze do you
remember that yeah i remember
i remember yeah and so it froze and it
glitched and then my whole ipad shut
down so i i did it again and i scored
three million five hundred instead so it
was like one
you know a little bit off but i was like
[ __ ] it i'll do it you know yeah
and so i was so she took a leader of the
board i took a photo i screenshotted it
the only thing that i've ever beat him
in
gaming wise
and then and then i got a three six
but you know why how much money did you
spend trying to beat me no money
[ __ ]
how many days did it take and how many
money how much coins did you use no no
there's no proof oh my god
there's no way to prove it i'll rest my
case i'm gonna rush my case let's go i'm
gonna call your accountant and look for
the itunes um
well if you see itunes would see it
you'll probably see you'll see simcity
on that no i'm going to look
specifically for bejeweled i'll go look
at it you know what i want you to do
that and when you do it yeah and i want
you to read it and i'm going to be right
next to you and when you lock guys we're
going to go in your [ __ ] face woman
because if you spent because i got a
three six
on my [ __ ] um uh a facebook account
and i'm number one she's number two i'm
the champion and that's a fact
an end of story so look at me you're
looking at a champion lady
lady marmalade i love you though oh
deeply well speaking of fighting um
okay about two weeks ago when we were
playing destiny
because we love destiny steve myself
eric griffin frank some other friends
were on it's like three four in the
morning
and my brother snapped
okay so can i well i want to defend
myself okay go ahead okay so there's a
thing on in destiny and it's the raid
and it's like one of the main hardest
things to do you need six people to do
it yeah
and do we make it it was the second or
third
level of that it was the third level we
were at the level where there's you have
to run to the totem yeah and then when
you get the death singers
thing yeah you have to it's like it's a
synchronized event what's the end goal
the end i don't even know what it is
you're just running back and forth you
just kill [ __ ] and no no no no yeah
there's people
there's hives to kill
okay synchronized thing and if yeah
somebody you have to do one wrong thing
you have to start from the beginning but
you guys aren't even six people
no okay so our fire team the og fire
team is me
him eric griffin craig efros my neighbor
frank
and then we needed one other guy
which was chris from seattle chris owens
from seattle yeah which is craig's
friend
so this is why it's not funny because no
one goes to the [ __ ] craig i know i just
want to give a shout out i don't see the
last name chris owen like where
everyone's oh chris given his twitter
handle
um so anyway i
i messed up because um when i when
you're at the bottom you have to be in
the middle of the totem mm-hmm
and i was offset of that
so i was dying
so
um i don't know i didn't know why i was
dying and
what happened i can't really what
happened was this
we when you die we have to start over oh
yeah so you can't mess up you can't miss
like yeah
my brother knows that he's [ __ ] up
oh you know so i was basically
frustrated at myself
and eric said what kind of gun are you
using and that right there and that that
trigger that's it oh my god
bruce
bruce banner to incredible hulk why is
that the trigger
he was already frustrated himself
because well the thing is would you say
to eric well i got defensive i go what
kind of gun are you using
right but not in that way
i go you are a mistake
what kind of gun are you using
huh
no i had a gun you use it it wasn't that
violent yes it was no no it was like
gail it was like what kind of gun are
you using okay yeah
so it was a little more between the two
in between yeah and i i cause i like
i i like all kinds there's different
kinds of weapons in destiny there's
scout rifles automatic rifles pulse
rifles and i've learned to love all of
them yeah and they all have it you know
their own different feel sure
i had us exotic exotic is the best
weapons you could get in the game
they're yellow and which exotic were you
using the mida or the meta multi-tool
very good it's a very very good gun it's
a very popular gun so shout out to that
gun
um
follow them on instagram yeah yeah yeah
um
and then afterwards i said i'm using the
meta multi-tool and i looked at his
character what are you using yeah and
then he had a normal vanguard scout
rifle yeah so i try to up like up one on
him yeah yeah my gun's better than you
yeah
and then what'd you say to poor frank
and then poor frankie by the way frank
god
messed up man so frank is another kid
that's enough
and he's a doorman at the comedy store
he's a nice he's developing as a he's a
nice kid he's a nice mexican kid such a
nice i know so what did you tell him i
don't know why out of nowhere i go what
do you got to say to that frank yeah you
want some too no he said okay no he said
no he said to this this is what my
brother said oh man
i could put you in a double leg takedown
right now i started talking about power
wrestling yeah yeah
wrestling i'm like don't help my staff
yeah i'd go check out the stats on
policewrestling.com yeah yeah i know i
know how to do double legs
i was like i was going back like 1993
like go to poway wrestling so he was i'm
not in frankfurt
physically threatening with power
wrestling stats and skills oh my god it
was
like you know what the idea what i can
do to you yeah i got a double leg you
wanted him to dig into the archives i
don't know it came out of nowhere like
where that was unnecessary and then
so now eric griffin now knows
that it's turning into a red zone
situation
and if you don't know if my brother gets
in the red zone somebody could die
no it's not that that's that bad it's
not that have you let me ask you a
question though have you attacked me
with knives
oh yeah and silver lake yeah
yeah yeah how many knives you're
attacking me with
your two knives in your hand and you got
two behind my back yeah i got into a
wrestling stance everything is wrestling
i know i don't know i don't know why
it's been so long yeah he got into right
oh it's deeper than that though because
i did choke at the state tournament and
i was ranked two in the country no no in
the states and um damn i always choked
at the state tournament
so yeah there's like it goes redemption
yeah it goes really really it goes deep
it is like the pain is deep so how ended
was um eric knew that steve was going
into a red zone and then and then eric
just goes
bye he goes bye
and he just clicks he just disappears
yeah eric griffin and i was like you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] yes yeah but eric's
gone now he can't hear us i'm like you
[ __ ] [ __ ] you're a [ __ ] yeah yeah
my brother goes off and then and then my
brother i i realized at that moment oh
no i'm the [ __ ]
in that moment
yeah because he left and it was silent
and then i go yeah well [ __ ] this man
and i turned off my machine yeah so my
brother appears and what happened after
everyone starts laughing everyone me
frank and the two other guys just start
[ __ ] laughing yeah
right because it's four in the morning
and also eric and steve are in their 40s
yeah we're old i don't know why we're
even playing this game these are 40 year
olds
we're addicted to this guy midlife like
people have mid-life crisis yeah four
kids
these guys are [ __ ] children yeah i
mean we laugh
it's on some nerdville [ __ ] man like
we're and we're not even good at it
we're not even good at it
we're not even good so what what did you
say last night oh you said something so
good last night what'd i say
i got you steve
[Music]
against three strangers yeah but the
three strangers
are the best got players yeah this is
the elite of the game the reason why you
do it is because
if you can finish this like little
bounty it's called the gold tier bounty
and you get it at the reef from brother
vance from brother vance gives it to you
and it's basically what the bounty is
you get 50 kills in trial yeah so no not
only 50 kills you need to complete like
seven matches right and so you go but
for 50 kill but 50 kills for us it'll
take us like eight hours we'll all night
and then the sun will come up
yeah yeah for us is a gigantic it's a
huge task right now teams get 50 kills
in just two rounds yeah uh it takes five
six seven hours it takes a whole night a
whole night but if you will we have to
keep going back to the reef and getting
past it's cool to come back yeah yeah
because you keep dying and part of the
game is you have to kill but then you
also can revive your teammates yeah so
i'm in this room and i guess we're
getting slaughtered like these three
guys
they killed me and basically it's
basically this you literally start and
then you're dead
oh because everyone is experts at
sniping they all have a sniper rifle in
the
yeah but anyway i got killed and and so
bob instead of
shooting the other guy
no no
all right all right well go ahead go
ahead well okay not only did he get
killed
we're in a room and frank's dead
steve's dead i'm alive and there's three
guys in the room with shotguns with
shotguns now
shotguns with shotguns i revive steve
and i go i got you steve yeah my brother
said my brother didn't shoot any of the
other guys he was just trying to go to
my orb my dead orb yeah and revive me
and he goes i got you still he used to
do something and
um i'm like i'm like what are you doing
it's yeah we you had to be there yeah
you had to be there but it was a it was
a good moment it was a great moment
because it made me realize
like we don't know what we're doing yeah
yeah we don't know what we're doing
you're supposed to shoot the dude he was
just trying to revive my body brotherly
moment but when you get a gold tier
though the reason oh my god
nice stuff yeah you could either get a
good gun
a chest all he cares about is the new
shoulder pieces and the chest pieces you
only care to look good you don't care to
have good guns right yeah
he just wants the the colors and the do
you know the visual yeah there's um and
osiris is different because everything
has an eyeball on yeah is it still
random like what you get is still around
yeah you've got [ __ ] left i got [ __ ]
yeah i did three gold tiers and what'd
you get i got like the worst thing like
the artifact like a necklace or
something like i got the artifact yeah
yeah so um
anyway i don't know why we're so you got
me into it i know i don't know why why
it's so a dick addicting like i don't
know why we keep playing yeah but we do
do
every time i'm on you're on i know but
has does he change because we've talked
about this does bob's demeanor change
yeah it brings out the worst parts of
him so he becomes really combative and
irritable and impatient
and um for instance if he's playing um
you can't he can't be spoken to he has
if you speak to him he takes that as an
offense yeah and he yells back he's just
it's so different he turns into a
completely type of different monster
when he plays these um
what do you call these type of games um
the shooter first person yeah first
person shooter games now what's the
difference between fallout and destiny
like he's peaceful like he wants to he
wants to cuddle have sex
when he's playing fallout yeah like he
becomes building houses you're just
building houses
[Laughter]
room after room yeah he's uh decor yeah
he doesn't decorate
he doesn't even want to have sex at all
when he plays destiny destiny like at
all
now is it partly my fault that you're
back in yeah well it's not your fault
stevie's a [ __ ] grown man not no but
but in one but it doesn't help when you
call me
at two in the morning collide
do you think bob can play
we're doing trials of osiris and i
really want this new gun so yeah
wow great impressions oh my god even
during the ufc fight
the whole fights were going on he taps
me on the back he goes yeah there's a
bunch of people on my house we're
watching the pay-per-view ufc
and he taps feels this little tap on the
back i'm like yeah
collide
hey
so tonight we're doing a firefly
fire tv
our fire team needs pop
yeah
yeah
yeah and then you could see because she
knows now that i'm the one that told you
to tell her no but she has a good she
always has a good response she's like
dude he's a grown-ass man he can do
whatever he wants but let's see that's
not what do you mean when you say
something like that what there's a lot
behind that
you think that's a loaded response from
me no it's no i'm just interpreting that
there are a loaded response you probably
just mean that at the way it is